the quest to understand the laws of
nature the deepest possible level has
been maybe one of the noblest and most
consequential aspirations of human
beings for for centuries now and in
fundamental physics we've understood
that to do this we have to go to the
extremes so we study the laws of nature
what the universe looks like on the
longest possible distances the largest
possible distances in cosmology but also
at the very very smallest possible
distances where we discover that matter
is made up out of elementary particles
that interact with each other
governed by fundamental forces and
rather surprisingly and very importantly
in the last hundred years we've learned
that what seems to be a dizzying array
of very different phenomenon turned out
to be much more closely related to each
other than would appear at first sight
and that these essential simplicity and
unity and and really beauty of the laws
of nature only reveal themselves when
you study nature under a microscope and
you and you look at what's happening at
very short distances or very high
energies so we've been going to this
short distance frontier high-energy
frontier for for four century now and
there's absolutely no reason to stop in
fact a machine very similar to the
machine that's being talked about now
was being entertained in the United
States already in the early 1990s a
superconducting supercollider the u.s.
tragically decided not to proceed with
that project but it's something we know
how to do the technology exists the
know-how exists and the scale of
resources that we're talking about is
not beyond the pale of of similar
projects in the past so that's the big
picture answer to this question we need
to build this collider because because
we can and because it represents the
frontier of what we've been doing and
studying the fundamental laws of physics
for centuries now